okay
thanks for joining us everyone um we've
got a panel discussion lined up for
today i'd like to thank everyone for
submitting questions
we have a lot of questions to get
through uh but first let's
meet our panelists um lance would you
like to start
oh sure yeah my name is lance casper and
i'm a technical specialist for
biocolumns
or field application scientist and i
work
directly with customers and being able
to help them with method development or
column recommendations
for any kind of biomolecule analysis
so proteins peptides oligos
glycans amino acids
etc great thanks lance
john
hi everybody my name is john yam i'm an
applications chemist with agilent
um supporting the glidecam consumables
portfolio
thanks john um david hi everyone
my name is david wong i'm an application
scientist in the
lcms solution team in the marketing
division
so my primary main focus is on the
biopharma
application development
thanks david kenda
thanks justin hi everyone this is kenda
evans
and i am an automation product
specialist
i focus on all the automation portfolio
for agilent
thank you thanks kenda and
aled hi my name's alex jones
i'm marketing manager for bioconsumables
and that includes
glycan preparation standards and
glycoenzymes that were brought into the
agilent portfolio as part of the
integration
of prozone
thanks alex thanks again for everybody
joining us uh really appreciate it i
think we've got a lot of great questions
lined up here
uh the first one uh that i think we
should tackle what are the major
analytical challenges of glycan
structural characterization
it's a pretty broad topic um john would
you like to get us started
sure i'll get started on that um so what
are the challenges
of analytical sorry the analytical
challenges of bike and structural
characterization
is that a question i'm correct one thing
that jumps out to me
at first would be um the different
isomers that you can encounter with
glycans so glycans are made up of
multiple monosaccharides they can be
linked in different fashions
and that can those end up being
different glycans um
so based on that it can be a challenge
to actually decipher the different types
of
isomers that can be present in a sample
that's probably one of the first things
i would think about
so anyone else that has them something
that they want to chime in on
uh hi this is david wong uh i agree with
john so
especially for the guy can iso isomer
so because i'm focused on the lcms side
or the mass back side of that analytical
uh area so i would say um
in order to confirm or identify the
um the guy came with a different isomer
so we need a good
msms fragmentation in order to uh
to do the structural characterization
so a good fragmentation and also
a library with all those msms data
of the department will be really helpful
great thanks uh how about any are there
other uh structural characterization
issues that that you've run across
um lance is there any solutions from a
chromatography perspective that might be
of assistance to people
um i guess i would point out that maybe
speed is a challenge uh because
like you said with all these structural
isomers we
there's a you know you have to take you
have to sort of take shortcuts or you
know you do
you base it on retention times and
uh you know to really get every single
linkage and exactly how that that glycan
um you know the complete structural
characterization
take it take some i guess some training
and
yes it's more difficult i guess than it
could be
and and from a chromatography standpoint
some of these samples are very complex
so getting full resolution is difficult
uh so things like 2d might start to
increase in popularity
how about use of exoglycosidases for
elucidating structures
john rowland would you want to touch on
that
yeah i can speak to that a little bit
and then you know
i'll just add by by stepping back first
of all and
you know it really is sample dependent
um
what the analytical challenges may be if
you ever
if you have a monoclonal antibody based
on igg
with only one one glycosylation site
um and a relatively um straightforward
glycogen profile
it might be an easier proposition than
say an ft fusion with multiple
anglican sites and potentially ode-like
n-sites as well
and that might determine which level you
start to look at like oscillation on
you know there were talks earlier today
from david and john
looking at impact mass subunits like a
pepside
and release glycan um and really what
sort of combination of those that you
use
might might depend pretty strongly on
the molecule
um that you have um with
with regards to exo's glycosidases um
this is um this is a technique that has
been used in the literature for
for quite some time and it can
potentially be used to um
to get to that isomer question that john
was talking about by using for example
stylobase
to trim off the uh the terminocaric acid
from from the non-terminal end of the
feminine-reducing terminal end of the
glycans
or galactosidase or hexosaminidase to
really get the structure id and this
combined with mass spec
and in terms of getting a mass id can be
pretty powerful can
could be a pretty powerful tool in uh
determining
uh the glycan species that you have in
your sample
great thanks alex uh let's move on to
the next question
um there's a a multi-part question here
uh that i'm going to direct it to david
because this is very much what you were
speaking to in your presentation earlier
what are some ways to improve glycan
detection using peptide mapping
and what modes and columns are best for
getting the most accurate glycan profile
i do have an epnox covering the geico
peptide area
so i would say to increase the glycan
detection so
first of all you need a column to enrich
the glycopeptide and also do a good job
in the
sample cleanup hotter the enrichment
for the mass backside so
i think our 6545 qtof is pretty
sensitive
already but you do you can optimize it
by
tuning the instrument into the peptide
level
so the the column i normally use for
glycopeptide that that is the
advanced bio glycan mapping column that
is the heli
based column and the mass spec
i use just a positive mode for
acquisitions
thanks there's a couple of additional
follow-up questions to this
could you provide some tips for
achieving deeper coverage of glycans at
the glycopeptide level via mass spec
and do you have any tips on reducing
metal adducts when analyzing
glycopeptides by mass spec
i think from my experience so because i
use the
the helix uh the glycan mapping column
for the glycopeptide
separation so one is the uh the tip is
that
um so one once you um
enrich the peptide glycopathy and
clean up and when you dry it down so
make sure you
resuspend it into about eighty percent
of
zero nitrogen solution instead of like
ninety percent
uh as the
dissolve the sample so so that it won't
the the peptide glycopeptide won't
precipitate
it or is make sure that all the samples
go into the solution before you make the
injections
and also i start with the five percent
of
the um the organic solvent not
not uh zero percent of water
so that that's make sure the samples
is all go into the column for lcms
analysis
for that um the metal add up um
again when you do the after the
enrichment so make sure you do the
sample cleanup
so that would pretty much get rid of
the most of the metal adducts in the
sample that
associated to the glycopeptide
thanks david okay so the next question i
will direct to uh to aled and john
um regarding rapid testing in the rapid
kits
that we've developed i think is what
this is referencing how do you
confirm the accuracy compared to
traditional glycan analysis methods
i guess i can start there i'll go ahead
and
okay i'll start and then i'll hand off
to john but um
you know the accuracy in terms of um in
terms of the relevance
in terms of the relative percent area
readout of each streichen species
i think is what the question is getting
to and
no it's important to determine that that
you're getting an accurate answer
in terms of the glycan species that you
have there so you know
compare back to a traditional method of
labeling
uh would be one of it that coupled with
the knowledge that with some older
methods
um there may be potential shortcomings
in either the d-like oscillation
labeling or the cleanup steps um so
you know really really taking a look at
each of those steps critically
um and seeing if um seeing if there's a
good match between
the traditional methods that you have
and the and the new method that you're
introducing
um i think that's an important step and
this is something that we can assist
with with our
um with our dry excellent glycan sample
puppets
jonathan further to add on that
um yeah i totally agree with what you
just said i think
when we developed these rapid kits we
took a lot of care
into making sure that um that the
readouts of the of the
of the glycan species were consistent
with
moving south older methods whether they
were traditional methods in the
literature or
our older generation like glycoprep
workflows and making sure they're
consistent and if we had you know some
type of
discrepancy trying to find an answer to
making sure that
um you know we're generating the best
answer possible
thanks so what about you know when when
people are uh
evaluating new methods versus old
methods what are some common uh
problems that they've run into you know
i areas that they might troubleshoot and
just
you know from from my own experience uh
if people are working off a uh an older
method that maybe doesn't have a very
robust egoic oscillation
and they're using a newer kit this may
be a little more robust they can see
differences there
what are some other areas that people
should be aware of as they're maybe
transitioning to these newer more
improved methodologies
i guess i can start there this time um
so one of the things i know with older
methods
um and also in addition to the diego
constellation step there's also the dye
labeling step right
um so if you were to let's say there's a
traditional method
the traditional design oscillation stuff
does overnight
perhaps some some of the glycan species
will be lost there
maybe there's a heating step or you can
maybe there's some stylic acids
um you know during the or for an
older method compared to a newer method
and also we have our new we also have
our new dies now right so we have
against npc which is much more sensitive
in terms of fluorescent and map and ms
so it's possible that you know maybe you
could be picking up things that you were
not seeing previously
in an older method
great points ella do you have anything
to add to that
not too much to answer that no i think
that's a good story
all right well let's move on to the next
question then um this will
also be another one for john's because
this is something that he was
highlighting in his presentation earlier
today
the question is is there a good method
to quantify stylic acid by using hplc
fluorescence
uh john i believe you alluded to uh some
things that we've been working on so
please sure yeah so i think i talked
about that in the presentation earlier
today
um so we'll be coming out with a new
workflow towards the end of the year i
think
it will um that will basically make this
possible
um this will be a this will be a
workflow to release
stylic acids label them with a 404 and
then separate them by lc
and then you can get um peaks for the
different gas and species
and um the workflow will include a um
quantitative standards that people can
generate a
standard curve and then use fluorescence
to um
to find out how much uh cellic acid they
have in their samples
great thanks sean let's see
uh next question here um would there be
differences in stylic acid quantitation
using mass spec versus fluorescence
detection uh and and i'm assuming here
the uh the person asking the question is
referencing
more of uh the siloated glycan species
and not say release stylic acid bmb
uh so john would you want to take the
first stab at that one
yeah sure um so i think when you're
trying to compare fluorescence
quantitation and ms quantitation
um now we have to understand that there
are differences in waves done
um so the glycans are labeled one to one
with force and dye so
across like a chromatogram you can
expect that the area under the curve
from the fluorescence of the four floor
will be representative
to help give you the relative quantity
looking for
when you're using ms and maybe looking
at
ion counts it'd be important to make
sure
making sure that all the potential
adducts are accounted for
that you can see in in the mass spectrum
to make to make sure that you're
accounting for as much as the possible
glycan species that are
in your sample to make sure that they're
they're accountable when you're trying
to relatively quants across maybe a
handful of different glycans in your
in your spectrum
and i think we have some older
application notes that have gone through
this
and compared both the fluorescence um
area
or yeah the fluorescence relative
percent areas as well as what can be
obtained by um
using aspect as well so if you have
those out there on the web i think
we can direct people to those if they
have um if they want to look at that
data specifically
great thanks john it looks like we just
had
another new question come through which
i think is is a good one for us to chew
on um
do you think that glycan analysis by ce
is limited
as compared to hillock and what are some
main differences to consider
um i'd bounce this one over to aled
first to get your thoughts what do you
think
um yeah it's it's an interesting one um
you know as as people may know we do
have sample preparation kits
um that support capillary
electrophoresis or ce
um most notably apts and we've done this
for quite some time
um formally as prozy and now as adam
and in the past we've seen ce really
be used as quite an effective orthogonal
method
in terms of um the glycan ellucian order
or in the case of ce migration order
um is a little different between lc and
ce
you know in ce the siloated glycans
appear first
in lc and hylic is the most common
technique for lc
these appear at the end so if you have a
particularly complicated sample
or if you want to increase confidence in
your
in your method ce is a good orthogonal
method
for this um at least in our hands we see
that um
lca lc is a little more flexible in
terms of the
in terms of the mass spec that you can
hyphenate on the back end to power up
the analysis and get the mass id
certainly this can be done though with
ce so i mean it really depends on your
preference
and um you know maybe what data you have
to uh
compare back to um i would say that both
have their place
although lc seems to be becoming more
prevalent at this point
at least for release at least for
release like an analysis
thanks alan let's see looking through
all these questions as we've received to
try to find
the next candidate here um
let's see so here's a pretty general
question what software tools does
agilent have to facilitate and automate
glycan analysis
david do you want to get started with
that one
yes so for for our biopharma um
the major workflow we have one workflow
called release guidecam
pro so we use the software
program called outcome phone and and
also
we have a preparatory geicon
database that has about more than 100
glycan
with the accurate mass information
so it's all on automatic
data processing and identification in
this workflow
thanks david along the same lines
there's a question
about um achieving identification of
unknown glycans and asking is there
a special msms software um
glycersoft is one mentioned as an
option i'm not familiar with that one
and then also asking if ion mobility can
help with isomer id
i can jump in as well um i'm not quite
familiar with the
that third party software with msms
capability
um so for the eye mobility uh
i'm pretty especially helpful
if we are looking at the isoform i
isomorph that i can
yes
great thanks john did you have anything
to add to that
no i think that's um that's pretty good
great okay um okay so next question i
see here um
what lance this one's for you uh it's a
it's a little
vague but i think uh what we're getting
at here is how to choose the best elsa
college so the question is specifically
what functionality group should i
evaluate to choose
the best lp column so maybe you can talk
about how people would select the right
lc column for their glycan separations
sure i mean glycan columns are
reasonably standardized in terms of they
are predominantly
hylic amide columns that's definitely
the
the main standard in terms of the
specific column with a specific vendor
that you would choose
that could depend on you know if you
want to have
if you have a uh plc and you want to run
really fast methods
you may want to use a sub 2 micron
column for the most resolution
if you're trying to have a method that
that goes into qc with older
instrumentation
then that might not be the best column
for you
and you know the different columns
definitely have different selectivity
so if you are running you know if you
have if you have a column that you
typically use
and you run into problems about
developing a method
then uh it's it's a good idea to try a
different
kind of different column even if they're
both hylic amide you could definitely
get different selectivity
and it might might pull apart the peaks
of interest
perfect thanks lance
john and alan we've got another stylic
acid question here i'll put
to john first um how does ph and
temperature in solution affect the
stability of stylic acid i'm not sure
how much information we have on that but
i'd like to get your thoughts
um that's actually a really good
question and i don't have a good answer
for it um i can do a little bit of
research maybe get back to the
questionnaire with um with that we could
keep this discussion offline
i'm okay with that alan do you have any
thoughts on it or do you want to take it
offline
i think so yeah i mean just to add that
we have seen um
you know we have seen with some of the
older methods that use reductive
emanation that uh some
some care needs to be taken um with the
heated labeling reaction
um to optimize time and temperature to
make sure
that uh that you don't get too much
desalination
so so that's certainly been a
consideration when looking at uh
labeling procedures for
um 2ab apts any dye that uses reductive
ammunition
for diets like instant pc
that use a um a 50 degree
labeling for a shorter amount of time
five minutes um this isn't
isn't so much of a concern
great thanks alan
okay um so i think we'll have uh time
for one more question here
uh and this one is is again prevay uh
but i think we we have a lot of
ideas that could help here so what are
some new developments in lc and glycan
analysis that could help streamline
sample prep and analysis
i think you know most folks in this
panel have provided presentations today
that kind of
highlight some of our new technologies
uh that do help with this workflow uh so
um
you know david you want to to take this
first and then we can
maybe just go around the panel
interesting so i'm not sure because
right now uh we
i i haven't tested that is called the
bio inner
biolc column i don't know whether that
would help for
the glycopeptide or glycan
separation because those are
the i don't know uh because i don't have
much experience on that maybe
alex can jump on it
i was going to say that you know we do
have you know a browner lc
and we have uh now we have uh some
helicons that were
packing with us peak lines stainless
steel hardware
so you know interaction with metals
would be reduced
uh using that type of column uh we don't
currently have a hylic amide
but our our zwitter ionic helix column
uh helix
z that we uh have it in the
in bioinair hardware that actually does
work for glycopeptides
so that that would certainly be an
option
yeah i mean in terms of workflow
advances
um so since the integration of the of
the former prozyn portfolio
um we've brought on a lot of vend like n
standards
um which enables you to plug these into
your workflow in terms of determining
the glycan species that you have in your
sample so i think that's a
that's an improvement on where things
were before and also since
since we've integrated into agilent of
course prozyn
um the former prozyn products have the
opportunity to be used
together with azure and columns and also
instruments
so i think that's what we're that's what
we're aiming towards is
um you know providing you with a
end-to-end workflow from
from standards all the way through to
all the way through to data analysis
and i can see that's only improving in
the next uh in the next year or so
with um you know standard offerings as
well as columns
i should also point out that we do have
um we do have the nismab
standard that is available now from
adjuvant
there have been many publications on
this on this material
mostly in multi-laboratory studies which
agilent also contributed to so this is a
a pretty useful standard in terms of a
monoclonal antibody that you can take
off the shelf and plug into your uh to
your glycogen workflow be it
intact mass on the glycopeptide level or
on the release lycan level
um and then and we have a nist map
compendium which uh
which uh describes all the relative
um all the all the related techniques
and
you know columns and consumables that we
offer to perform this analysis
great thanks aled well said i think
that's a great place to wrap this up
i really appreciate everyone's time
today thanks to all the panelists
and thanks for everyone that submitted
questions we really appreciate it
and i hope everyone has a great day
thank you thank you thank you
you